Miriam has been in Tijuana with her daughters
for a couple of days.
The journey from Honduras has been long and
difficult.
Their goal is almost within reach - the US
border.
They don't want to stay in Mexico for long
- the authorities have little to offer them:
They are making no effort to provide food.
To be honest, the food they are giving us
is awful.
Look, here are beans that you would only give
to pigs.
But we have to eat it, because otherwise we'll
die of hunger.
They will sleep on the floor again tonight
in the city stadium, which the local authorities
have provided as a makeshift shelter.
They have been overwhelmed by the migrants,
who have come in greater numbers than expected.
Mario Osuna, who manages the improvised shelter,
says they're dependent on government support.
We were simply not prepared for this.
We have no contingency funds, we rely on the
federal government for those.
We can set up shelters out back, in the fields,
and provide assistance.
But a lot of federal support is needed for
us to help the people who are already here,
and are still to arrive
They need as much as four million dollars,
according to the spokesman for the State Human
Rights Commission.
He admits that the city is currently unprepared
for the impending arrival of more migrants.
There's not enough staff to receive all those
who will arrive.
That is why we have been putting pressure
on the government.
An application for about 80 million pesos
was submitted to the federal government.
That's how much the local government estimates
will be needed for the migrants."+++
Some locals have been dreading the arrival
of the Central Americans, fearing chaos and
costs.
They have to relieve themselves.
Where will they do it?
There is no capacity at the sports facility.
There aren't enough toliets for that many
people"We have given them a place to sleep,
drinks and food.
But then in the news, we see that they are
ungrateful.
That's truly disappointing.
I was just starting my motorbike, when a boy
insulted me.
We almost got into a fight because he offended
me.
Increasing tensions have led local authorities
to impose tough security rules.
The migrants are not allowed to enter or leave
the stadium after 10 at night.